on today's episode were mixing it up
moving the chairs and adding a mic to
bring you the perspectives of not one
but two researchers on the topic of
human-computer interaction we hope
you'll enjoy this first in a recurring
series of multi guest podcasts where we
dig into HCI research from more than one
angle offering a broader look at the
wide range of ideas being explored
within the labs of Microsoft Research
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using if you want
to know what's going on in the world of
human-computer interaction research or
what's new at the KY conference on human
factors in computing systems you should
hang out with dr. Ken Hinkley a
principal researcher and research
manager in the epic group of Microsoft
Research and dr. Mary Rangel Morris a
principal researcher and research
manager in the ability group both are
prolific HCI researchers who are seeking
from different angles to augment the
capability of technologies and improve
the experiences people have with them on
today's podcast we get to hang out with
both dr. Hinckley and dr. Morris as they
talk about life at the intersection of
hardware software and human potential
discuss how computers can enhance human
lives especially in some of the most
marginalized populations and share their
unique approaches to designing and
building technologies that really work
for people and for society that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
so I'm excited to be hosting two guests
in the booth today both working under
the big umbrella of HCI or
human-computer interaction
I'm here with dr. Ken Hinkley from MSRs
epic group which stands for extended
perception interaction and cognition and
dr. Meredith Rangel Morris aka Mary of
the ability group Ken and Mary welcome
to the podcast thank you thank you so
I've just given our listeners about the
shortest possible description of the
work you do so before we dive deeper
into your work let's start with a more
personal take on what gets you up in the
morning tell us in broad strokes about
the research you do why you do it and
where you situate it Mary why don't you
give us a start here sure one of the
reasons that I'm excited about working
in the space of HCI every day is that I
think computers are cool but what I
think is most interesting about
computers is how people use computers
and how computers can help people and
how computers can enhance our lives and
capabilities and so that's why I think
HCI is a really important area to be
working in when I did my undergraduate
degree in computer science at Brown they
actually didn't have any faculty in HCI
and the first time I heard of HCI was
when Bill Buxton who is actually a
researcher now at Microsoft came and
gave a guest lecture in my computer
graphics course and so we had that one
lecture where Bill talked about HCI
and when I heard that I was like wow
this is the most interesting thing I've
heard about in all my courses so then I
you know found a way to work on that
topic area more in graduate school Ken
what about you what gets you up in the
morning sure well I guess the first
answer is my dog and my kids often early
when I would defer but beyond that I was
interested in technology at a young age
but it was not for the sake of computers
themselves but like what is this
technology actually good for and I
remember going through a phase early
maybe sophomore year in college as we're
interested in artificial intelligence
and so forth but I started thinking
about it was like whoa
why would you actually want to do that
like why would you want to make a
computer that's like a human it's really
more about the humans and how can we use
technology to augment
their thinking and their creativity to
do amazing things so that's what excites
me about being at Microsoft Research and
having research that's getting out in
terms of devices and experiences where
people can do amazing things with the
tools and the techniques that we're
building I want to set the stage for the
research we'll be talking about by
getting a better understanding of the
research groups near what comes out of
can you work in the epic group we
referred to what that stands for and you
called your interdisciplinary team a
pastiche of different expertise since
we're using French words tell us more
about epic and its glaze on debt yeah I
should have been cautious with my use of
French words I did study French in high
school but I've forgotten all of it and
my accent is terrible but the core sort
of mission of epic is to innovate at the
Nexus of hardware software and human
potential so there's really sort of
three pillars there there's the hardware
so we do sensors and devices and kind of
new form factors we explore that like in
terms of new technologies coming down
the pike we also look in terms of the
software like what can we do in terms of
new experiences and actually Mary
mentioned Bill Buxton earlier he's
actually one of the people in the team
and so we think a lot about what is
happening at this you know as new
technologies come forward like how do
they complement one another how do they
work together how do we have not just a
single experience but experience that
sort of flows across multiple devices
and everything all the technology are
touching in your day it's still this
incredibly fragmented world and we're
trying to figure out interesting ways
that we can sense or provide experiences
that give you this flow across all the
technology you're touching in your day
and then we also study and sort of the
human side we study the foundations of
perception and motor behavior and like
these very fine-grain things about how
people actually perceive the world and
it turns out it's you know there's some
interesting things that go on there in
terms of how you form sensory
impressions when you're hearing
something and seeing something and
feeling something all at the same time
or maybe not in a virtual environment
for example so there's tricks you can
play sometimes so we sort explore that
as well I want to drill in just a little
before we go on to Mary I've looked at
the scope of your team it's a really
diverse group of people in terms of
where they come from academically and in
their research interests talk a little
bit about the kinds of people on your
team and that pastiche that you referred
to sure
so we have people you know people like
Bill Buxton you come more from the
design world she started an electronic
music right so that was his motivation
for technology back in the 1970s we have
people like Mark Gonzales Franco who
comes from neuroscience background and
gives us some of that you know real
interesting insight in terms of how the
human brain works we have people from
computer vision like a all effec who's
leading a lot of forward convergent
environments and haptic perceptions so I
mean it really kind of spans all those
areas we also people from information
visualization people from multiple
countries you know Korea France
Switzerland so it really is like kind of
people from all over the world and we
really value that diversity of
perspective that it brings in terms of
what we bring to our work right so Mary
last May we talked about what was then
the newly minted ability group on this
podcast it's episode 25 in the archives
but as it's been about a year now since
that came out let's review tell us
what's been going on over the last 12
months and what the ability group is up
to now absolutely so as you mentioned
we've already talked about the ability
team on another podcast and our primary
mission is to create technologies that
augment the capabilities of people with
disabilities whether that's a long-term
disability a temporary disability or
even a situational disability and we
have a lot of new projects that we've
started in the past year a big one is
the ability initiative which is a
collaboration that spans not only many
groups within Microsoft Research but
also externally to a partnership with UT
Austin and this project is focused on
how we can develop improved AI systems
that can combine computer vision and
natural language generation to
automatically caption photographs to be
described to people who are blind or in
the situational disability context maybe
someone who's sighted but is using an
audio-only interface to their computer
like a smart speaker and so we're trying
to tackle problems like how do we
include additional kinds of detail in
these captions that are missing from
today's systems and also the really
important problem of how do we not
reduce error but how do we convey that
error to the end-user in a meaningful
and an understandable way so that's a
really big new initiative that we've
been working on another big initiative
that we've just started up with some new
personnel is starting to think about
sign language technologies so there's a
new postdoc Danielle Bragg who joined
the Microsoft Research New England lab
and her background and experiences in
sign language technologies like sign
language dictionary development for
people who are deaf and hard of hearing
so actually together with Danielle and
also Microsoft's new AI for
accessibility funding program we
organized a workshop here at Microsoft
Research this winter that brought
together experts in deaf studies sign
language linguistics computer vision
machine translation to have a summit to
discuss kind of the state-of-the-art in
sign language technologies what are the
challenge areas what is a plan of action
going forward how can the Microsoft AI
for accessibility initiative accelerate
the state of the art in this area
so that's a really exciting new area of
work that we're interested in give me an
example of where sign language
technology plays I'm actually trying to
envision how would it manifest for a
person who had hearing disabilities
right now the state of the art is very
far from realizing automatic translation
between English and sign language it's a
very complicated computer vision program
and a very complicated machine
translation program because since sign
language doesn't have a written form
there are no existing paired corpora so
for example you know many famous works
of literature or newspaper articles you
know exist online in say both English
and French since we're talking about
right today and so that gives you data
from which you could begin to learn a
translation but since there's no written
data set of American sign language that
becomes very difficult to do and so how
you might generate training data is one
of the challenges that
we discussed at the workshop but if you
could have a computer vision based
system a machine translation system that
could recognize sign language and
provide English captioning that could be
an important communication aid for many
people and then of course vice versa in
the other direction if you could go from
English to generate a realistic animated
avatar that signed that's content that
would actually be really important for
many people because many people who
speak sign language sign language is
their primary language English is a
second language for them and so their
English literacy skills are often lower
than people who learned English as a
first language so just English captions
on videos or English language content on
the web is often not very accessible to
many people who speak sign language and
signing avatar translations of that
content would open up web accessibility
but developing these avatars to sign in
a realistic fashion and signing involves
not only the hands but facial
expressions and so actually generating
that nuance in an avatar is a very
challenging research problem I've had a
sizeable number of your colleagues on
the show all of them have stressed the
importance of understanding humans
before designing technology for them and
to me this makes sense you're in
human-computer interaction human being
the first word there but it's remarkable
how often it seems like nobody asked
anything at technology so give us your
take on this user first or user centric
approach that comes out of this umbrella
of HCI but particularly within your
groups why it's important to get it
right and how you go about that can why
don't you start sure I do subscribe to
the user centric approach to interaction
design in the human-centric maybe is the
more particular word because you really
have to understand people before you can
design technology that fills this
impedance mismatch between what you can
do with technology and sort of the level
at which people operate and think about
concepts however in my own research I
often take sort of I call it a pincer
maneuver strategy right so you think
about you know what are the fundamental
human capabilities how do people
perceive the world how do you interact
socially with other people but then you
can sort of couple it with you see
things coming down the road
terms of oh there's these new
technologies coming out there's new
sensors coming down the pike and so what
I often try to do is I try to match
these trends that I see converging and
when you can find something where you
know say a new sensor technology meets
some need that people have in terms of
how their interaction with the devices
and you can sort of change the equation
in terms of making that more natural or
making the technology sink into the
background so you don't even have to pay
attention to it but it just seems like
it does the right thing I like to do
that so I really do play both sides of
the fence type I study people and I try
to understand it deeply as possible
what's going on there but I also study
the technologies and so sometimes I do
have work where it's more technically
motivated first so it's a bit contrary
in that sense but it always ends up
meeting like these real-world problems
and real-world abilities that people
have and trying to make technology as
transparent as possible
Mary how about you I can give actually a
great example from the sign language
workshop that we were just talking about
of the importance of this user centered
design so one of the important
components of this workshop was having
many people who are themselves deaf who
are sign language communicators attend
and participate in this ideation and
this session and one of the themes that
came up several times that speaks to the
importance of user centered design was
the example of sign language gloves so
there are quite a few examples of very
well intentioned technologists who are
not themselves signers and who didn't
necessarily follow a user centered
process who have invented and reinvented
gloves that someone would wear that
could measure their finger movements and
then produce a translation into English
of certain signs but of course this
approach doesn't take into account the
fact that sign involves many aspects of
the body besides just the hands for
example so that's one pitfall and then
of course also from a more
socio-cultural perspective another
pitfall of that approach is it thinks
about sign language technology from the
perspective of someone who's hearing so
it's placing the burden of wearing this
very awkward glove technology on the
person who is deaf whereas for example
maybe a different perspective would be
people who are hearing should wear
augmented reality glasses that would
show them the captions and the people
who are deaf wouldn't be burdened by
wearing any additional technology
and so I think that kind of perspective
also is something that you can only gain
by a really inclusive design process
that maybe goes beyond just involving
people as interviewer user study
participants but also actually having a
participatory design process that
involves people from the target
communities directly as co-creators of
Technology yeah can do just something to
add yes maybe one more thing I'd add in
terms of my own perspective so I sort of
mentioned how it's really important to
understand people and sort of what goes
on but I think one of the interesting or
unique attributes of that is I think
we're trained here in Microsoft Research
in terms of understanding people is we
sort of become these acute observers of
the scene but the unnoticed so there's
lots of these sort of things that we
just take for granted in terms of
interpersonal interactions like if
you're at a dinner party and you're
talking to a group of people like well
you're probably forming a small circle
and probably there's five or less of you
in the circle right and there's a
certain distance that you stand and
you're facing each other in certain
characteristic ways none of this is
something that we ever noticed another
example I like to use from my own work
and sort of working on tablets and pen
and touch interactions this is actually
just looking at how people use everyday
implements with their hands and my talks
often ask people like okay well which
hand you write with of course you know
75% of the audience will raise their
right hand because they're right-handed
and of course I'll say well actually
you're wrong because you use both hands
to write it because first you've got to
grab the piece of paper and then you
orient it with your left hand and then
the right hand does their writing so
there's examples like that in terms of
what people actually do with their
behavior that because we just take them
for granted it's just part of our
everyday experience you don't actually
notice them but as a technologist you
have to notice them and say like oh if
we could actually designer interactions
be more like that it'd be natural the
technology be transparent
[Music]
well let's talk about research now Ken
I'll start with you and maybe the best
approach is to talk about the research
problems you're tackling around devices
and form factors and modalities of
interaction and how that research is
playing out in academic paper and
project form especially with some of the
new work you're doing with posture where
interfaces so kind of big picture about
some of the projects and papers that
you're doing yes so in terms of the
global problem we're trying to solve
we've been thinking for a long time
about these behaviors that are seen but
unnoticed everyone goes through the day
using maybe their mobile device or if
you have a tablet your interact with
that in certain ways and there's always
sort of these little irritations that
maybe you don't really notice them but
over time they build up and using
technology we can mediate some of these
so to go back you know actually almost
20 years now we were looking at mobile
devices and you had to go through
certain settings you could go in the
settings say oh I wanted to be in
portrait mode now if you're taking some
notes or maybe you need to look at a
chart you had to go back in the setting
say oh I wanted to be in landscape
orientation and so we started looking at
oh you know if we had some sensors like
a little accelerometer that was on the
device you know maybe we could actually
just sense which where you're holding
the device in the screen could
automatically rotate itself I mean so
that was something that you could
publish as a you know we're running
paper in the year 2000 and now it's like
sort of in everyday use right so taking
that same perspective now to mean the
modern era of interacting with tablets
how do you actually understand how the
person is using their device and what
they're trying to do with it so tablets
have this interesting attribute where
you can use them directly on your
desktop you may be you're doing some
very focused work you can kind of be
leaning over it and writing with your
pen maybe marking up some document you
know or maybe you're just kicked back in
your couch and watching like YouTube
videos of like cats chasing laser
pointers right so we kind of in that
whole spectrum but obviously it's
particularly the situation right so if
you're kicking back in your couch you're
probably not trying to mark up your
Excel spreadsheet and likewise if you're
kind of hunched over your desk you're
probably not watching the cat video so
by sensing those contexts and actually
adapting the behavior of the tablet so
it understands how you're holding it
what's hand you're grasping it with are
you holding it on the bottom are you're
holding on the left to the right are you
holding the pen in your hand are you
reaching for the screen by being able to
sense all those attributes we can
actually simplify the experience and
sort of bring things that are useful to
you at those
moments well in it's interesting that
you referred to that toggle between
landscape and portrait mode which is
actually annoying to me I sometimes lock
my phone because I don't want it to go
there I want it to stay there but anyway
that's a side note I know but it's funny
because we actually noticed that when we
first built that technique and we kind
of knew that was a problem with it but
actually our most recent research now we
can also sense how you're gripping the
phone and so you can understand that if
you lay down and your grip and the
devices not changed we know that you
didn't intend to reorient it so we can
actually now suppress screen rotation
finally 20 years later that's exactly
the problem because I would lie down and
want to read it sideways and there like
that with my head well Mary let's talk
about the work you're doing in the
accessibility space particularly for
people with low or no vision we might
expect to see this manifested in real
life I like to say IRL or on the web or
other screen applications that's just
sort of how I think about it
but you've taken it even further to
enhance accessibility in emerging
virtual reality or VR technologies which
is fascinating to me so give us the big
picture look at the papers and projects
you've been working on and then tell us
about seeing VR which is both the paper
and the project as I understand it I
think this project initiative around
accessible virtual reality is trying to
think okay virtual reality isn't that
commonly in use right now but in 10
years it's going to be a big deal and we
want to think about accessibility from
the beginning so that we can design
these systems right the first time
instead of trying to have post hoc
accessibility fixes later so part of the
aim of this work beyond the specific
prototypes like the controller or seeing
VR is really to start a conversation and
just raise people's awareness and be
provocative and have people think oh we
need to make VR accessible so if people
only remember one thing that's what I
want them to remember separate from the
details of the specific projects but yes
so last year we presented at the KY
conference that controller which was a
novel haptic device that allows people
who are blind to our white cane users
IRL to transfer their real life skills
into the virtual environment
in order to navigate and actually
physically walk around a vr environment
with haptic sensations that mimic the
sensations they've got from a white cane
and then that project was led by our
fabulous intern you hong jiao from
Cornell Tech and also with strong
contributions from our intern Cindy
Bennett from the University of
Washington who is herself a white cane
user so she had some really important
design insights for that project and so
you hung returned last summer for a
second internship and she wanted to
extend the accessibility experience in
VR based on her passion around
interfaces for people with a low vision
so low vision affects more than 200
million people worldwide and it refers
to people who are not fully blind but
who have a visual condition that can't
be corrected by glasses or contact
lenses and so working together with you
hung and also several people from Ken's
team like a all effec and Mike Sinclair
as well as Andy Wilson and Cristian
Holtz from M s Rai and also at Cattrall
from my team this was really a big
effort we developed seeing VR and so
seeing the art is a toolkit of 14
different options that can be combined
in different ways to make VR more
accessible and we went with this toolkit
approach because low vision encompasses
a wide range of abilities and so we
wanted people to be able to select and
combine tools that best met their own
visual needs and the great thing about
seeing VR is that most of these tools
could actually be applied post-hoc to
any unity VR application so unity is the
most popular language for developing VR
and so even if the application developer
hadn't thought about accessibility
beforehand we can still apply these
tools and so for example the tools do
things like increasing the magnification
of the VR scene changing the contrast
adding edge detection around things that
you can more easily tell the borders of
different objects being able to point at
objects and hear them described out loud
to you special tools for helping you
measure the depth of different objects
in case you have challenges with depth
perception and so we'll be presenting
seeing the are at Kai this year and will
not only be presenting
paper but we'll also present a
demonstration so people who want to
actually come and try on the VR headset
and experience the tools directly will
be able to do so well that's a perfect
segue into talking about KY the
conference it's a big conference for HCI
maybe the biggest yes it is and
Microsoft Research typically has a
really big presence there so talk about
the conference itself and why it's a big
deal and then give us an overview of
what MSR is bringing to the party in
Scotland this year in the form of people
papers and presentations sure so in
terms of you know some of the papers
that people on my own team touched yet
we have a couple of the honorable
mention Awards which is sort of
recognizes the top 5% of papers
appearing at the conference so one in
particular we talked about the you know
censoring posture awareness and tablets
another one that's a really fun effort
is using ink as a way to think with data
right so think about inking kind of
thing so if you have some sort of
visualization that you're looking at in
your screen what if you could just sort
of mark up some data points and simply
by marking it up as you're thinking
about and just sort of glancing at these
visualizations so then you take sort of
these simple marks that people would do
anyway in terms of using you know very
pen and paper like behaviors but now
translate it to a digital context on
your tablet for example I can just mark
something up with my pen and then I can
use those marks as ways to actually link
the data points back to the underlying
data can I actually split my data set
just by drawing a line across that as
opposed to doing some complicated
formula and that's our active ink
project so instead of just having you
know sort of dead ink on paper you can
actually imbue it with this digital life
that actually it just naturally how
people think but then you can just start
going deeper and deeper in terms of it
actually touches a lot of data that's
underneath go ahead Mary what I wanted
to point out was the paper at CAI from
Microsoft research that I find most
exciting this year is one of the best
paper award winners the guidelines for
human AI interaction work that was led
by Salima Mercy who's a researcher here
in the redmond lab I'm really glad this
paper won the best paper award because
it has a lot of immediate practical
value for people in the HCI and AI
communities so if you're gonna read one
paper from Kye this year listening
audience I'd suggest you read this one
it has a list of 18 very concrete
actionable guidelines
for developing AI systems that are meant
to be used by real people in a way
that's pleasing to the end-user and it
has lots of good examples and counter
examples of applying each of these
guidelines so I think it's a really
great read and I'm glad it was
recognized with the award any other
highlights that you want to talk about I
mean you've got colleagues Stephen
Drucker has a couple papers I think in
there and Cecily Morrison who is out of
the UK lab and I mean there's tons of
great stuff in a sense it's an
embarrassment of riches because even
myself being at Microsoft Research I
haven't had a chance to look at all this
work I haven't looked at the HCI AI
paper that Mary just mentioned so now
it's like I've learned something from
this podcast you I need to go read this
yeah in terms of other areas that we're
addressing there's actually quite a bit
of work on virtual environments coming
from Microsoft Research so just looking
at different ways that we can manipulate
things in VR and very unique and sort of
crazy in creative ways so we have worked
exploring that we also have work
exploring in terms of if you're in a
virtual environment actually want to
reach out and touch something your hand
is just an empty space so how do you
give the illusion that there's actually
objects you can interact with and give
you short of dextrous ways to knit plate
them so we've been doing a series of
technologies around how to simulate the
you know grasping emotions for example
so you can actually feel an object you
can squeeze it and it feels like a task
compliance we have other work looking at
personal productivity when you have
wearable devices and just numerous other
topics even in terms of like can you use
the language of graphic novels as sort
of a way to present visualizations that
people see a sort of these data comics
or data toons we call them just
exploring that as sort of another
language for interacting with data so
there's all kinds of great stuff going
on
so you mentioned Cecily Morrison so
Cecily and her collaborators from the UK
lab we'll be presenting a demo at Kye
this year of code jumper which I believe
you interviewed her about in another
Millicent has code jump it was a project
Tory know and it's been renamed but
that's a tangible toolkit for children
who are blind that they can use to
actually learn programming skills
themselves and so that will be on demo
at CAI for people to try out I think
besides all the papers another thing to
point out is that many people from
Microsoft research are involved in
organizing workshops and so one that
I'll call out is there's a workshop at
the workshop on hacking blind navigation
that discusses the challenges of
developing indoor and outdoor navigation
technology for people who are visually
impaired and IDI control from the
ability team is one of the co-organizers
of that workshop but that workshop is
going to feature a panel discussion that
includes Melanie nasal who is an
engineer on the soundscape team here and
so as you may know a soundscape is a
Microsoft Research app that uses spatial
audio to provide a unique outdoor
navigation experience for people who are
blind so Melanie will be speaking at
that workshop and then the workshop will
also be featuring some research from an
intern annie ross from the University of
Washington who was co-advised between
the soundscape team and the ability team
and what Annie was looking at was a very
different take on accessible virtual
reality so she was thinking about
designing an audio-only ritual reality
experience that would allow a soundscape
user to practice walking a route in the
comfort of their own home or office
before they actually walk that route in
the real world and it's a very
challenging design problem and so she'll
be discussing that at the workshop also
[Music]
so it's about now that I always ask the
infamous what keeps you up at night
question your work has direct human
impact perhaps more directly than other
research that we might encounter and
often with people who are marginalized
when it comes to technology Mary I'd
like you to start this one since I know
you're involved in work around AI ethics
and some of the work that's going on in
the broader community about that so what
are your biggest concerns right now and
how and with whom are you working to
address them yes so there's been
increased awareness both in the industry
and in the public consciousness over the
past year or so about some of the
fairness and ethics challenges of AI
systems but a lot of that discussion
rightfully so has focused on issues
around gender and race but one thing
that I've noticed in these conversations
is that there hasn't been any discussion
around these issues as far as how they
might impact people with disabilities
and one goal of mine for the coming year
is to really elevate awareness and
conversation around this issue so for
example are people with disabilities
being included in training data because
if they're not AI systems are only as
good as the data so as an example if you
think about smart speaker systems like
an Alexa or a Siri or a Cortana do they
recognize speech input from someone with
a speech disability so if you have
dysarthria or stutter or some other
atypical speech pattern and the answer
in general is no because people with
those speech patterns weren't included
in the training dataset and so that
locks them out of access to these AI
systems well you might want to add
children there's a video about a little
girl asking Alexa to play baby shark and
never ever gets it until the mom comes
in and says it in the right way well
absolutely and that goes back to a
longer historical issue the original
speech recognition systems were trained
only on men so they didn't even
recognize women's voices at all if you
want to look back several decades so yes
there are many groups people with
accents children that all come to mind
and
that's a big issue I think another
example of an ethical issue particularly
for sensitive populations like people
with disabilities is expectation setting
around the near term capabilities of AI
systems I think a lot of the language
that's used by researchers and marketing
people when we talk about AI leads
people to overestimate the capabilities
of anti systems I mean even just the
word artificial intelligence suggests a
human-like semantic understanding which
really today's AI systems are all about
deep learning it's all just statistical
pattern recognition with no semantics at
all and so I think we want to go back to
the sign language example I feel like
every month I see some kind of headline
that says you know researchers have
invented a sign language recognition
system but then if you actually read
between the lines you know they've
invented a system that can recognize 50
isolated signs which is nowhere near
recognizing a whole language and I think
for people whose lives may be
fundamentally changed by these kinds of
technologies being careful about how we
communicate the capabilities of AI
to those audiences is really important
so in terms of going forward with this
issue of raising awareness around issues
around disability and AI fairness I've
been collaborating with Megan Lawrence
who's from the office of the chief
accessibility officer as well as Kate
Crawford from the New York City Lab
we've been organizing some external
events to raise awareness around this
issue
Megan led a panel discussion at the
recent CSUN conference and the three of
us co-hosted a workshop last month at
the AI now Institute so I think you'll
be hearing more about this topic in the
future Ken aside from having a French
test that you didn't study for is there
anything that came for you up at night
anything that we should be concerned
about
yeah my research it doesn't keep me up
at night it's kind of I'm really looking
for what are some unique ways that we
can add to human potential so for me
it's a very satisfying and very exciting
topic to think about so it doesn't keep
me awake it kind of gets me excited at
night or maybe it keeps me up because
I'm just my mind keeps buzzing with
creative new ways that we can use
technology to kind of amplify
human thought to make us so people can
express new and better or maybe more
expressive concepts and they would you
know with pen and paper and physical
materials I often like to return to you
know Kranz Berg's laws are sort of a way
to think about this in particular the
first one where you know basically the
gist of it is that technology is not
inherently good nor is it bad but nor is
it neutral right so it just kind of
exists out there and it's often you know
human desires and needs and those shape
how technologies get applied and we need
to think really carefully about that and
when we're bringing something new into
the world so yes I don't really like the
approach of like oh let's just build
something and kind of hope it works out
you really need to do think carefully
through like what is the human impact
and is this actually going to empower
people and make it so they can do new
things I love stories and one I'd like
to hear is how you two know each other
and another is how you each ended up at
Microsoft Research so Ken tell us your
story and then we'll have Mary talked
about how she in her own words wormed
her way in here yes so I was a graduate
student at the University of Virginia
and I was a computer science student but
my desk was actually situated in the
neurosurgery department and most of my
funding was through some grants to the
neurosurgery department hat because they
had these really interesting medical
image datasets of you know MRI scans of
patients are coming in and the lab I was
working with actually working on ways to
create new tools for neurosurgeons so
they could actually access these things
directly and look at them so they were
looking for tools to visualize and plan
surgeries so that was my entree into the
world of HCI and research so George
Roberson had been a sort of one of the
pioneers of 3d interaction at Xerox PARC
he had moved over to Microsoft Research
he was starting up a team here and see
like hey can you oughta come works with
them on these things so we started you
know doing that and just over time you
know because there's so many great
things going on here in Microsoft
Research there's lots of opportunities
to jump to different topics so I started
working with Mike's and Claire and you
saying like hey look I got this new
accelerometer sensor and maybe you
should try putting that in your phone
stuff that you're looking at and so
that's where this automatic screen
rotation came from for example so that's
sort of how I ended up here on this
track of exploring devices and so forth
great segue into my story
the automatic screen rotation so that's
how I met Ken and I don't even know if
ken knows this story because it was very
important to me at the time so I was a
student at Stanford
in the computer science department
during my PhD and it was my first year
of school and ken was an invited speaker
for the seminar series and Ken spoke
about this work that he and Mike had
done on attaching the sensors to the
phone with the rotation and it was an
amazing talk and amazing project but
also it was the first time I had heard
of Microsoft research because I was a
brand-new grad student and so I was
really impressed and after that talk I
thought oh I really want to get an
internship at Microsoft Research but
it's a very competitive internship and
usually they want students who are
further along in a career who already
have a track record of publication so I
wasn't really a competitive applicant on
paper and so then a couple months later
I attended the HCI C workshop and at
this workshop I met a different
Microsoft employee who invited me to
come interview for a more product
oriented internship and so they were
gonna fly me up from California to
Seattle so I took advantage of the fact
that I was gonna be in Seattle and I
mailed Ken and I said Ken you know I'm a
student Stanford I heard your talk it
turns out that I'm gonna be in the
Seattle area next week while I'm there
could I come talk to you and your group
about internship opportunities and so I
kind of snuck my way in the back door to
having this on-site interview at the
time and I did get the internship and I
ended up actually spending my time that
some are working with Eric Corbett since
Susan Dumais who were part of the same
team but it was because of seeing Ken's
talk that I managed to worm my way into
Microsoft research and then you went
back to finish your studies and then
came back here huh right because I had
such a great experience at that
internship I was very focused on
becoming a professor of computer science
but I had a great experience at my
Microsoft Research internship and so
Eric and Sue and all of the people that
I worked with really encouraged me to
come and also interview with Microsoft
for research and so that's how I ended
up back here ken what do you remember of
that that's fantastic
I do remember talking with Mary after
the I gave this talk advisor Terry
Winograd invited me down to give a talk
another sort of wonderful person in our
field but yeah but I was definite
impressed by Mary she asked me a lot of
great questions after the talk and you
know sometimes you get students coming
up afterwards but then they don't really
say anything that kind of gets to the
next level so I remember Mary asking a
lot of really good questions and so I
was very interested in bring her in as
an intern but as it turned out I didn't
actually have an intern shot to offer
anybody that summer so it's great that
she sort of managed to work her way into
actually getting in the building and I
think sue was the one who actually had
the internship to offer and sue Dumais
is I don't know if she's been on these
podcast or not but she's also wonderful
I'm sort of one of the people here at
Microsoft research that I look up to the
most so it was even better than
opportunity with me but working with sue
is wonderful and Mary's just continued
to blaze new trails and just every topic
that she touches so it's been great
Mary what's fascinating about what you
just said and you're not the first one
who's told a story about eight kind of
bold move it's like take a risk why not
right absolutely
that's how I wormed my way into grad
school too I had heard Bill Buxton's
lecture about HCI we didn't have HCI at
Brown I did some searching about HCI in
the internet and came across one of
Terry Winograd projects at Stanford and
so just out of the blue I emailed him
and said I read about your project on
the Internet
I'm an undergraduate computer science I
really want to get to know about HCI
research
can I come spend the summer with you
working and he said yes and that was how
I got involved in HCI research did a
good job he offered me to come back for
graduate school but if I hadn't sent
that email it never would have happened
so I guess the lesson is a be bold and
advocate for yourself well you kind of
just answered the last question I'm
gonna ask you which is at the end of
every podcast I give my guests a chance
to talk to our listeners with some
parting thoughts maybe wisdom advice and
stories about how being bold got you
what you wanted so here's your chance to
say something you believe is important
to researchers who might be interested
in making humans and computers have
better interactions ken what do you
think I think for me in terms of like
what I see working well and having good
research outcomes I see lots of people
they try to sort of plan out this grand
scheme of like oh I'm going to do this
and this and this and my PhD and you
kind of outline everything to death but
where the really exciting sort of
nonlinear breakthroughs come in is you
just start walking down this path and at
some point you're kind of beyond the
area where the lights are from the city
right and you're kind of out in the
wilderness in the darkness and you're
like well I'm not quite sure where to go
but you just start trying things right
you've basically just try ideas see what
works see what doesn't work and then
from that you take the next step and if
you're kind of willing to just take this
approach where don't try to plan
anything out but be willing to walk off
into the darkness in terms of just
exploring unknown terrain that's where
the really interesting things come up
Mary what do you say I guess my advice
would be around just being curious and
as part of that asking questions I know
that for years I think it was at least
five years after I had my PhD before I
felt confident enough to ask a question
during a talk instead of just waiting
afterwards to talk to the speaker
one-on-one because I was worried like
obvious there's questioning what people
think I'm stupid or they'll think I
don't understand and after I ask
questions you know I realized that like
lots of other people had the same
question as me so not only did I learn
new things but I helped enrich dialogue
at the conference and the conference
experience for other people and a lot of
times asking these questions needs two
really good conversations and
collaborations and new research ideas
afterwards so I think my advice is to
ask questions that's what research is
all about isn't it ken Hinkley Mary
Ringel Morris thank you so much for
joining us today it's been really fun to
have two people who play off each other
and have great stories thanks for coming
on the podcast thanks for having us
that's the show much
[Music]
to learn more about dr. ken Hinkley and
dr. Mary Lou Morris and their
up-to-the-minute research in
human-computer interaction visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]